WESLEY CHUN: Hi.
This is Wesley Chun from Google.
You may know me as a longtime
member of the Python community,
but in this episode,
I'll try to actually use
some of those skills to
show you how you can change
the world by building a
globally accessible app starting
with just 10 lines of code.
Yes, I'm giving you an
idea for your next startup.
Assuming you want a wildly
successful business,
time to market is
of the essence,
so you need to move
quickly and use
tools that get your
service out there sooner.
One idea is to come up with
an MVP, or Minimally Viable
Product-- quickly to
see whether we can build
a service without a web or
mobile app, both of which
can come later.
Instead, we can simply
create a bare bones service
that users can reach.
How are we going to do that?
Well, what's one thing that
everyone online has access to?
That's right-- email.
We've all got an email from
a person or a computer,
and you've probably
sent email to a person.
But have you ever sent
email to a computer?
Well, you're going
to learn it now,
because that's
what's allowing you
to skip native implementation
for V1, because email
is compatible across all
devices, mobile or desktop.
This also means
that we're looking
at building an app
that receives email.
Now why is an app that
receives email a big deal?
Well, many services send email,
but that's less interesting,
because it's just a
single function call.
Now being able to receive and
process those messages, that's
more intriguing, and as you can
tell with the big bang here,
I think much more powerful.
Your users email your
service, and your app
responds to those requests.
Think about it.
You typically email a person,
but can you just as easily
email an application?
Of course.
On top of that,
users don't really
need to download another
app since email is already
likely available
on their devices.
By allowing users to send
commands to your service,
you've opened up the door
to many possibilities,
such as updating user
settings, transferring money
to a relative, reordering all
that prescription medicine,
making a small purchase, or
turning on or off the TV,
heater, or alarm at
home or a business,
all from an email message
that's coded correctly and sent
to your service.
Imagine emailing your mom
and then emailing your house,
say to shut off the lights,
because you left so early
for the airport this morning.
Doesn't that sound crazy?
Well, automated processing
is also more scalable,
enabling the ability to process
hundreds or thousands of email
messages and performing
service requests
in a very short period of time.
Now, it's very much of
a client server model
if you're familiar with that.
So anyway, how can we possibly
do this in 10 lines of code?
By leveraging Google
App Engine, so you
don't have to worry about
things like the hardware,
the operating system,
network programming,
databases, and most
importantly, email servers.
Similarly, Python
lets you get a lot
done with very
few lines of code.
The syntax is pretty easy, so
even if you don't know Python,
you can still follow along in
this tutorial and mentally map
to your favorite
programming language.
However, while this video
is beginner-friendly,
we're not going to introduce
you to developing on App Engine,
so if you are new, just do
the Getting Started tutorial
that's online,
and you'll be set.
When you're ready, create a
new Hello World app either
using the Launcher UI that
comes with App Engine when
you download it or copy
the code from the tutorial,
because we're going
to start from there.
We only need to edit
the app.yaml config
file and the main main.py
Python controller file.
Believe it or not, building this
app only requires a few steps.
One, create the skeleton app.
Done.
Step two, enable
receiving email.
It's just a config change.
Three, bring in the library code
that supports email handling.
Four, add the code that
uses that library, and five,
route all inbound email
messages to the handle
that you wrote in step four.
Step two is just a
config change, right?
So add these two
red lines of code
that you see here to your
app.yaml config file.
It's a new section
called Inbound Services,
and it goes right above
the Handler section.
App Engine supports
several inbound services,
but the one we care
about is email.
So that's what we do.
And that's it.
Your app can now receive email.
All the other code
changes will take place
in the controller, which is
main.py, so let's go there.
Now let's bring in the
App Engine component
that handles receiving email.
Oh, by the way, we
took out the comments
that were auto-generated
at the top,
so that it's easier
to see the code.
So now add these two
red lines of code.
Line 1 is import logging.
What we're doing
in the prototype
is to log the senders
of the email messages
that our app receives.
Obviously, you can do more,
but we're just getting started.
Line 3 imports the
App Engine code
that handles the
receipt of email,
as you can probably guess.
Well, why are the import
lines in this order?
Well, it's a Python
best practice.
System imports like logging come
first, followed by third party
library codes, such as webapp2.
Next are any local SDK Tools,
such as the App Engine APIs,
and finally, if we had any local
modules, those would go last.
Now let's handle incoming email.
This is done by adding this
three-line handler class.
The receive method pulls out the
sender's address and logs it.
Now there are
other email message
attributes that you can access,
because to change the world,
you're going to have
to use everything
else like the email
subject and body
and the sender and
receiver email addresses.
All right, the final step--
redirect all the inbound email
requests to the handler
that we just added.
When someone points their
browser at your app,
and sees Hello World, how do
you think that actually happens?
Line 14, it forwards
the request for slash,
which is your homepage,
to the main handler
on lines 5 through 7.
Think of the app variable
on lines 13 through 16
as the dispatch table of
where we forward requests.
Each route comes in the form
of a path and handler 2-tuple
so we need to add something
similar for inbound email.
When App Engine
handles inbound email,
messages will be posted to
your app at that special path,
which is /_ah/mail/emailaddress.
Since we're going to handle all
emails with the same handler,
we'll use a regular
expression-- or regex--
matching all such addresses,
hence why we have dot plus.
That redirects to email handler.
Oh, by the way, don't
forget that trailing comma
at the end of line 14, which
is why it's kind of red too.
Otherwise, you'll
get a runtime error.
Hey, I just helped you
pass an interview question,
so feel good about it.
And that's it.
Ignoring the imports
and blank lines,
we're left with about 10 lines
of code that do all the work.
Now if you're really
pedantic and recognize
that the routing table is
actually just one single Python
statement, well, you can
cut that down to seven,
and if you're only counting the
number of lines that we added,
well, it's down to six.
Amazing!
Believe it or not, this
is a fully working app
that does the basics.
We don't have a web app, unless
you count the Hello World bit,
and neither did we create an
Android or iOS mobile client,
right?
But you could.
And easily, by using
Google Cloud Endpoints.
You can click on the video
there and check it out.
All right.
Now let's run it.
The App Engine SDK comes with
a development server, or dev
server, which lets
you run your app
locally to test with before
you deploy live to Google.
When you do this by either
clicking run on the launcher UI
or using the command line
tool, make sure, by the way,
that you note the port numbers
for both the main app as well
as the admin console, because
we're going to use both.
Point your browser at the
main app at local host 8080.
You should see the main handler
in action rendering Hello
World.
Since we're only in dev, you
can only simulate sending email.
And to do that, you need to
get to the dev server admin
console.
So now point your browser at the
other port, which is local host
8000.
Once you're there,
what we really want
is the inbound mail link in
the left nav, so click that.
You'll see this form to
send a fake email with.
Before we do that, let's talk
about what we're sending first.
Recognize you're going to have
to validate every message,
because you're going to need to
make sure that every request is
real, not spam, not fake,
and most importantly,
not sent by someone on
behalf of someone else.
Invalid messages coming
from unrecognized users that
don't follow your
security protocol
like a secret passphrase
or two factor auth
or just aren't
structured correctly
can simply be dropped
or logged as desired.
As you can see in the
message body here,
we've got a lot of stuff
that can be potentially used
for this purpose
if we were creating
more than just a prototype.
All right.
Enough business logic.
Let's talk about sending email.
So App Engine apps receive
email sent to any address
of the format
xxx@APP_ID.appspotmail.com,
where xxx is a recipient,
and your app ID is the host.
Be sure to use appspotmail
in the domain name
rather than appspot.com.
In this demo, let's pretend I
created this awesome service
for our press team, allowing
them to issue new press
releases with a single command.
We're using the Publish
command for the recipient.
Receiving email is
our fake app ID.
By the way, that's really
someone else's app,
so don't send anything
there if you're
going to run in production.
It doesn't really
matter in the dev server
as no emails are actually sent.
Once you click Send and see
Request Succeeded message,
check your logs and verify
that your handler was called.
Click the Logs button
in the launcher
or check out the command line
output sent to the console.
You should see
Received a Message
From whatever fake
sender address you used.
Running this live in production
requires only a few more steps.
Make sure you've got
that unique ID plugged
into your app.yaml file.
Then go to the
launcher, and click
Deploy to send your code to
Google after authenticating.
Or you can also use
the command line tool.
Once the app's uploaded,
check that it's
up by going to the Hello
World page in the browser
just like we did
for the dev server,
only you'll be pointing
at yourappID.appspot.com.
Now pull up your favorite, warm,
cozy-up-by-the-fireplace email
client to send a real
email message to your app.
Again, it should go to some
xxx@yourappid.appspotmail.com.
After sending, go to
your Apps Admin Console
at cloud.google.com/console,
selecting your app,
and clicking App Engine
in the left nav bar.
In the App Engine sub
nav bar, click on logs.
In the middle of
the admin screen,
you should see exactly what you
wanted-- your email handler's
log message.
Booyah!
What do we do next?
Well, if you want
to skip the typing
and get straight to the
source, click the link
to download the zip file.
If for some reason, you
want a slower step-by-step,
a full treatment can be found
in the Google App Engine
chapter of Core Python
Applications Programming.
Otherwise, that's it.
We've just built a Python
App Engine app together.
It can receive email.
It's less than or equal
to 10 lines of code.
Now it's up to you
to change the world.
Seriously, you've got the
makings of a new business here.
Go out, and be successful on
the Google Cloud Platform.
Thanks for tuning in.